Hi zusammen! Wir starten heute mit der Subway Woche
und wir beginnen mit dem wohl beliebtesten Brot überhaupt: Cheese Oregano.
Ich liebe das! Und bei Subway sind die Brote auch immer so richtig weich.
Also da kann man so richtig reindrücken und keineswegs innen knusprig oder so!
Und das machen wir heute, also das Rezept dazu!
Ich glaube, wir bestellen uns auch nur Cheese Oregano, oder?
[Hamza] Eigentlich schon!
[Kiki] Eigentlich schon.
Und wenn überhaupt, dann mal vielleicht Vollkorn, das mag ich auch sehr gerne!
[Hamza] Unbezahlt ist das hier, ne?
[Kiki] Ja, ja, ja! Das ist natürlich alles unbezahlte Werbung!
Das ist keine Kooperation! Wir machen das einfach weil wir grad Bock drauf haben und ihr auch!
Und ihr durftet ja auch auf Instagram abstimmen, welche Rezepte auf jeden Fall vorkommen sollen.
Ich starte jetzt direkt. Ich nehme jetzt die Küchenmaschine,das geht natürlich auch mit den Händen, ich find's so jetzt ein bisschen einfacher.
Ich gebe jetzt mein Mehl rein, allerdings nicht alles. Ich zeige euch das mal.
Es ist halt immer schwierig, das dann rückgängig zu machen.
So das lasse ich jetzt erstmal weg, das kommt gleich dazu.
Und da werd ich jetzt so eine kleine Mulde bilden und da gebe ich dann lauwarmes Wasser dazu.
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen übrigens wie immer...?
[Hamza] ..in der Infobox!
[Kiki] In der Infobox!
So, da gebe ich jetzt das lauwarme Wasser in die Mitte, ganz vorsichtig.
So, und da kommt jetzt frische Hefe dazu
Und ihr könnt euch auch Trockenhefe nehmen, die würdet ihr dann zusammen mit dem Mehl vorab vermischen.
Da dann noch ein bisschen Zucker als Nährstoff, kurz verrühren und dann 5min stehen lassen.
So, als nächstes kommen Salz und Olivenöl dazu
und dann werde ich anfangen, das kneten zu lassen
und später schaue ich dann, wieviel Mehl ich noch dazugeben muss.
So, jetzt habe ich auf der Arbeitsfläche zu ende geknetet.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr diesen schmalen Grad zwischen "noch klebrig" und "gerade so nicht mehr klebrig" hinbekommt.
Super wichtig! Und dann habt ihr ein perfektes Ergebnis und der Teig ist sehr, sehr geschmeidig.
Ich forme den jetzt noch so ein bisschen zu einer Kugel (muss nicht perfekt sein), benetze den Teig komplett mit Olivenöl
und dann lasse ich das 45min lang zugedeckt gehen.
So, jetzt ist die Ruhzeit um. Jetzt nehme ich den Teig raus und der ist richtig schön aufgegangen!
Gebe den auf meine Arbeitsfläche und dann teilen wir den durch 3,
wir bekommen nämlich genau 3 Baguettes raus.
[Kiki] Passend zum Baguette-Blech, da passen nämlich auch 3 drauf!
[Hamza] Also 2 für mich und 1 für dich!
2 für mich und 1 für dich, ja!
So, einmal durchteilen und dann schön länglich formen,
aufs Baguette-Blech geben und dann zugedeckt nochmal ca. 15min lang ruhen lassen.
So, jetzt habe ich den Ofen vorgeheizt auf 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze und ich bereite jetzt auch noch das Topping vor.
Ganz, ganz wichtig! Sonst würd's ja auch nicht Cheese Oregano Brot heißen!
Ich hab jetzt hier Parmesankäse und das werde ich hier ganz fein reiben in meine Schüssel rein,
gebe da Oregano dazu, vermische das schon mal und dann kommt das auf die Baguettes.
Und damit das haften bleibt nehme ich jetzt kein Eigelb, keine Butter.
Ich hab das Rezept nämlich vorher ein paar Mal ausgetestet bis es mir perfekt gefallen hat
und am besten fahrt ihr wenn ihr wenn ihr wirklich einfach nur Wasser nehmt.
Also Wasser drauf pinseln und dann die Mischung dazugeben.
So, 25min später: Mein Brot ist fertig!
Bitte nicht zu lang im Ofen lassen sonst wird's trocken!
Also die 25min, die waren jetzt perfekt.
Und.. ohh, es riecht so gut!
Wenn ihr das nur riechen könntet!
Macht's bitte unbedingt nach, allein schon für den Geruch!
[Kiki] Allein schon dafür, dass wir mehr Parmesan und mehr Oregano draufpacken als bei Subway!
[Hamza] Ich wollt grade sagen: Da ist mehr drauf, auf jeden Fall!
Ja, dadurch dass man's Zuhause nachmacht, kann man sich nach Belieben noch mehr drauf tun, was ich mega geil finde!
[Hamza] Subway ist ja immer gierig!
[Kiki] Naja, naja!
Boah Leute, ich möcht mir das als Parfum bitte draufmachen an den Körper! Das ist so geil!
Auf jeden Fall wünsche ich euch jetzt viel Spaß beim Nachbacken!
Ich werd das Video an der Stelle zwar beenden aber wir belegen das natürlich noch!
Mit was wir das belegen, das seht ihr dann in den nächsten Videos!
Ihr könnt mir gerne eure Kommentare unten da lassen, darüber freue ich mich wirklich immer sehr!
Und ansonsten..Hamza, hast du noch was zu sagen? Außer dass du Hunger hast?
[Hamza] Ich bin auch gespannt womit du das belegst!
Wir haben's nämlich 19h und wir haben noch nicht gegessen weil wir warten natürlich auf die leckeren Subs.
Und hinterlasst meinem Video unbedingt ein Däumchen nach oben wenn euch die Subway Woche gefällt!
Ansonsten freue ich mich über ein kostenloses Abo und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezeptvideo.
Tschüüss, eure Kiki!